on Sunday senator Bernie Sanders took to
Twitter to deliver one of his usual
messages people go to the doctor because
they're sick get a diagnosis from the
doctor but they tend a full of the
treatment he wrote how crazy is that so
I responded snarkily I go to a fancy
store to check out a piece of furniture
and I can't support it totally crazy
this of course prompted spasms of
apoplexy on the left how could I dare to
compare medical care furniture was I
equating the two was I suggesting that
the necessity of furniture was somehow
comparable to the necessity of medical
care of course not because that would be
stupid I was pointing out that medical
care is a commodity and that in life we
are often faced with commodities we
cannot afford but this mere observation
caused a ruckus on the Left necessities
don't compare to luxuries said one angry
tweeter blessed characters like ben
shapiro for demonstrating the complete
soullessness of capitalist ideology
tweeted another the idea here seems to
be that unless you declare medical care
or right rather than a commodity your
soul was that as marks might put it in a
subsidy rather than autonomy creates
rights this is foolish both morally and
practically morally you have no right to
demand medical care of me I may
recognize your necessity I may offer
charity my friends and I may choose to
band together and fund your medical care
but your necessity does not change the
basic math medical care is a service and
a good provided by a third party no
matter how much I need bread I do not
have a right to steal your wallet or
hold up the local bakery to obtain it
steph's may end up being the least
immoral choice under the circumstances
that doesn't make it a moral choice or
suggest that I have not violated your
rights in pursuing my own needs but the
left thinks that declaring necessities
right somehow overcomes the individual
rights of others if you're sick you now
have the right to demand that my wife
who is a doctor care for you is there
any limit to this right do you have the
right to demand that the medical system
provide life state and care for ever to
the tunes of millions of dollars of
other people's taxpayer dollars or
services how exactly can there be such a
right without the government ration and
care or using compulsion to force
individuals to provide it or
confiscating maxims of wealth to pay for
it the answer nope them work that way
right spits arrive from individual need
inevitably violate individual autonomy
in response to my tweet my colleague new
york magazine chevy single rogue quote
free markets are good at some things and
terrible at others and
silly to view them as ends rather than
means that's not true free markets are
expressions of individual autonomy and
therefore they are ends to be pursued in
and of themselves now practically
declaring medical care right doesn't
make it actually happen Justice Ruth
Bader Ginsburg said at one point she
would model new constitutions on the
South African constitution which
guarantees quote everyone has the right
to have access to health care services
including reproductive health care the
state must take reasonable legislative
and other measures within its available
resources to achieve the progressive
realisation of each of these rights
that's what the South African
Constitution says but the World Health
Organization ranked South Africa
somewhere near the bottom of the globe
in terms of medical care what happened
why didn't the right self-actualize
because medical care is a commodity and
if you treat it differently that's
stupid to make a commodity cheaper and
better you need two things profit
incentive and freedom of Labor the
government destroys both of these things
in the health care industry it decides
medical reimbursement rates for millions
of Americans particularly poor Americans
this in turn creates an incentive for
doctors not to take government-sponsored
health insurance it regulates how
doctors treat with patients the sorts of
training doctors must undergo the sorts
of insurance they must maintain all of
this convinces fewer Americans to become
doctors under supply of doctors
generally and of doctors who will accept
your insurance specifically along with
over demand stimulated by government
driven health insurance coverage that
leads to mass shortages the result in
overreliance on emergency care costs for
which are distributed among government
hospitals and insurance payers so what's
the solution for poor people well
Matthew declare medical care right
certainly not to dismiss reliance on the
market as some sort of perverse cruelty
markets are the solution and medical
care just as they are in virtually every
other area if you treat medical care is
a commodity that means temporary
shortages and it means some people won't
get everything we wish they would have
but that's also true but worse with
government-sponsored medical care as the
most honest advocates will admit and
whereas government-sponsored medical
care requires a top-down approach that
violates individual liberties generates
over to man and supply markets
prize individual liberties that reduce
demand you don't demand more of what you
have to pay for and they heighten supply
through profit incentive so back to the
furniture now let's say your life
depended on this choice today you either
have to obtain an affordable
chair or an affordable x-ray which would
you choose to obtain well if you're not
stupid you choose to share that's
because there are lots of types of
chairs produced by scores of different
companies widely distributed you can buy
a fifteen dollar folding chair or $1,000
antique without the slightest difficulty
by contrast to obtain an x-ray you'd
have to work with your insurance company
wait for an appointment and then haggle
over price why because the medical
market is way more regulated thanks to
the widespread perception that
healthcare is a right than the chair
market does that sound soulless true
soullessness is depriving people of the
choices they require because you're more
interested in patting yourself on the
back by inventing rights than by
incentivizing the creation of goods and
services in health care we could use a
lot less virtuous signaling and a lot
less government or we could just read
Bernie Sanders's tweets while we wait in
line for a government-sponsored surgery
dying presumably in a decrepit chair I'm
Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
alrighty so there's a lot to get to
today for some reason there are certain
songs playing in my head like raindrops
keep falling on my head and shower the
people you love with love but we will
get to all of that the media have lost
their minds by the way they've
completely lost mines trumped in a press
conference today and basically I can
give you the short version of what that
press conference looked like here's this
short version right there yeah that's
that was Trump versus amaze me huh and
then we have actually a quick live shot
of CNN headquarters right now yeah
there's there's that so we'll get to all
of that in just a second first we have
to thank our sponsors helix sleep helix
sleep they make fantastic fantastic
mattresses so I as I've said before on
the program I am a very light sleeper so
I require a very comfortable bed and he
looks sleep makes that happen for me
you'll go onto their website which is at
helix sleep calm and you fill out a
questionnaire and ask kind of your body
type how you prefer to sleep which you
prefer sleep on your side your back
what's your weight how's your body
weight distributed do you like it a soft
or firm mattress and then they send a
mattress to your house it can it can
even make mattresses that are customized
for each side of the bed if there are
two people and and that means that be a
sentence you in the mail you unwrap it
it inflates because it's a foam mattress
and then you put it down you sleep on it
and you try it for a hundred nights if
you don't like it then they'll take it
right back they will take it right back
and they will for a full refund if you
don't love it 100% refund guarantee it's
great you should totally try it it's
mattresses solid masters are really
expensive helix sleep is cheaper it's
also better we actually took a more
expensive mattress and we put it in the
other room because you liked the helix
sleep mattress better if you want it go
to Q explique calm / ben helix sleep
calm / bed if you buy a customized
mattress and can cost thousands of
dollars i know this does not it can cost
well under a thousand dollars over at
helix sleep calm and if you use the /
been number one you're showing that we
sent you but number two you get fifty
dollars off your order helix sleep
fantastic sponsor check them out helix
sleep calm / been okay wow so so many
things happened since we last spoke so
many things and they
are all hilarious so no one said the end
of the world wasn't going to be an
absolute circus of joy and that's
exactly what it has been it has been a
circus of absolute joy and wonder so all
of this starts last night when CNN
begins the news tsunami by running a
story about how US intelligence
officials have briefed president-elect
Donald Trump and President Obama about
these rumors these intelligence reports
that suggest that Trump has been working
with the Russians and that the Russians
have all what they call compromise which
means they have I guess they have some
compromising information on Trump and
that they're going to blackmail Trump
essentially here's what CNN reported
quote the allegations were presented in
a two-page synopsis that was appended to
a report on Russian interference in the
2016 election the allegations came in
part from memos compiled by a former
British intelligence operative who's
past work US intelligence officials
consider credible the FBI is
investigating the credibility and
accuracy of these allegations which are
based primarily on information from
Russian sources but has not confirmed
many essential details in the memos
about Trump the classified briefings
last week were presented by four of the
senior most US intelligence chiefs that
be DNI clapper FBI director Comey CIA
director Brennan and NSA director Mike
Rogers so basically they present these
supposedly classified documents to Obama
and Trump including allegations that
Russian operatives claims have
compromising personal and financial
information about Trump and that's the
extent of the story and so the entire
world goes nuts this is nuts right I
mean Trump is being briefed on the fact
that the Russians now have all this
dirty info and maybe this explains why
Trump is so warm toward Russia all the
time now to skip forward in the story
for a second CBS News appears to now be
blowing this out of the water they now
say that this never happened according
to the CBS News a senior US intelligence
official with knowledge of the
preparation for the meeting with Trump
said that Trump was not briefed on the
two page addendum to the dossier and the
multiple officials say the summary was
included in the material prepared for
the briefers but the briefing was oral
no documents were handed to trump so
that means that even the CNN story
wasn't true if the CBS News report is
true but this CNN story breaks and the
entire world is lift aflame the entire
world goes on fire just it just blows up
and then and
then the world ends right so it's
already blowing up and then the pieces
implode themselves and create a black
hole of news that's because Ben Smith
and BuzzFeed so BuzzFeed releases the
actual memos that were supposedly
compiled for this for this briefing for
Trump and Obama and these memos are
insane they're insane I mean they say
things like crumbs lawyer Michael Kohn
was in the Czech Republic meeting in
Prague with Russian agents to get
information on Hillary Clinton they say
things like Trump is deep in bed with
Russian business sources and that they
paid him lots of money it says that
Putin has been cultivating Trump is an
asset for years and of course the most
the most trafficked allegation and the
reason I'm making PP jokes today I'm not
enough of a man not to make a good urine
joke I'm sorry I can if you're if you
wanted if you wanted PP jokes you're in
luck today because today is your day but
one of the allegations is and it's too
it's too salacious not to mention the
allegation is that Trump went to Russia
and stayed at the Ritz in Moscow and in
state and it's ridiculous stayed in
Barack Obama's sweet the one that he
used to stay in with Michelle Obama and
then proceeded because he hates the
Obamas to hire a bunch of Russian
to to come in and have a golden shower
party to pee on the bed in front of it
because that's how much he hates the
Obamas and this thing is flying around
the web golden shower is trending and
and Ben Smith releases this statement
trying to explain why it is that he even
put this thing out because he himself
says in the report they say that this
stuff is unverified we don't know how to
check it there's no way to check it
we're going to put it out anyway screw
it we're putting it out too quick by the
way they'd already been run by a bunch
of other people including David Korins
David corn of Mother Jones he didn't put
out the full report here's what he
tweeted about it this is a said I
accurately characterize the memos this
is important stuff but did not publish
details even Donald Trump deserves
journalistic fairness but not from
buzzfeed so Benton Smith right as you
have probably seen this evening we
published a secret dossier making
explosive and unverified allegations
about Trump and Russia I wanted to
briefly explain to you how we made the
decision to publish it we published the
dossier which can been
singer obtained through his
characteristically ferocious reporting
it's not ferocious reporting to just
released a document so that as we wrote
Americans can make up their own minds
about allegations about the
president-elect that have circulated at
the highest levels of the US government
so we're just going to release this
information we're not going to provide
you any way to verify it but you do it
you do the verification or you're
supposed to do the verification that
sort of BuzzFeed job it's why all of
these other news outlets ripped into
buzz feedings and what the hell are you
doing but BuzzFeed releases it anyway
this this report that is chock full of
total crazy towns I mean total crazy
towns now it's possible that the CNN
report is quazy it's somewhat more
legitimate than the BuzzFeed report the
buzz view report is just here's the
document we obtained put it online and
we're not going to tell you whether it's
true or false also russian speed
on Trump right that was basically the
BuzzFeed report the CNN report said ok
we have sources that say the Intel
community reported this to trump that
raises questions about halcyon and knew
that is the Intel community leaking I
mean this entire campaign has been about
leak so I guess eventually we're going
to arrive at this point where it's leaks
about leaks but you know that's said the
there's there's Mark a minder at the a
mark a minder at the atlantic he said
that the the intelligence community
didn't just summarize the dossier it
also includes other information in any
case BuzzFeed runs this and the world
goes insane and very quickly Trump is
able to debunk some of this stuff very
quickly trumpet but we'll get to Trump's
response in just a second so first
before we get to that fortune which is
sort of the the trolling the trolling
website whether all of the best roles
are on 4chan its troll central that's
where all the cave trolls hang out and
4chan releases a statement basically or
people from 4chan saying that they have
actually created the stuff from whole
cloth and they sent it to an anti-trump
operative named Ruth Wilson Republican
in Brooke Wilson and Wilson gave it to
the Intel community so they trolled the
entire intelligence community there's no
evidence that this is true other than a
couple of people on 4chan sayings and
stuff there really is no evidence that
this is true Wilson himself denies this
he says that all this information has
been out since August that's the same
thing that was being reported by CNN so
there's no reason to think that
what 4chan said is true there's also no
reason to think that what BuzzFeed put
out there is true so we have a bunch of
unverified information floating around
and people taking sides and then Russia
jumps in so the Kremlin gives a response
and the Kremlin tells CNN quote the
Kremlin has no compliments on
president-elect Donald Trump according
to Putin's spokesman Dmitry Peskov
compra matters the Russian term for
compromising information intended to be
used against someone and the Peskov said
the Kremlin does not have compromised on
Trump information does not correspond to
reality is complete fiction and then
another and then he also said that we
don't even do this but they actually
said that there is that they actually
said that they don't even spy on people
then even do compromise compromise isn't
even something that we do which is no
that is if you think the Russians don't
gather information on people that'd be
crazy so now we finally get to the net
would finally get to the Donald Trump
team response and Trump is been handed
the ultimate gift just this massive gift
by BuzzFeed because imagine it is just
in the CNN report that said that there
are reports that he had heard about all
of this and that the intelligence
community was checking it out that's all
we knew well then he'd have some
questions to answer wouldn t but that's
not all that happened right instead you
get this BuzzFeed report that very
quickly people start going through and
debunking so for example Michael Cohen
who is the lawyer for Trump and is
mentioned in this in this compilation of
supposed intelligence on Trump he
immediately tweets out and he says no
I've never been to Prague and then
that's confirmed that he's never been to
Prague USC says that he was actually at
USC on the date that he was supposed to
have been in Prague CNN comes down says
always a different michael cohn a
different michael cohn not one who
worked for Trump to some guy named
Michael Kohn okay well that's weird all
right and then the and the Trump team
comes out and they say this is this is
just pure garbage runs previous White
House chief of staff he says this is
just nonsense this is made up so what is
the president likes response to the
BuzzFeed and CNN reports and will he
talk about them at eleven o'clock
Juventus press conference well i mean
the the BuzzFeed memo is total complete
garbage is what it is and I look
buzzfeed themselves said it was garbage
the new york times wouldn't even print
the document because it was unverifiable
this is what this is there's a pens of
thousands of retired agents all over the
world you've got some agent somewhere
maybe in the UK that hangs a shingle and
says pay me a rate i'm going to do
opposition resource search he does a
memo or she does a memo this thing
circulates for months it's
unsubstantiated and voila it shows up I
I talked to Michael Cohen one of the
basis of this entire report is that a
guy named Michael Cohen who works for
the Trump Organization went to Prague
and had a meeting with Russian agents
he'd never been the Prague in his life I
don't know what it says about the report
in fact the coach of USC baseball and
Southern California said wait a second
he wasn't in frog he was with me in
Southern California with his son well I
mean I've never been there are against
Southern California fog light all right
what is all of it and obviously you know
he's doing that on good sourcing this is
the beauty of what BuzzFeed did actually
in favor of Trump right by releasing all
this information half of which is I mean
a lot of which is for all we know all of
its garbage but some of it certainly is
garbage by doing that they allow Trump
the ability to come out and say
everything that we've ever heard about
Russia is untrue there's nothing going
on with Russia all of this is crap and
the media is out to get me because guess
what the media was out to get him here
right they actually were out to get him
Seth Meyers head on Kellyanne Conway
last night and he asks her about the
Russian report and a Kellyanne Conway
slaps him around a little bit Myers has
Ronnie's grilling her what she's
actually saying it's true because NBC
news came out and said that it was not
attended to the document and it wasn't
mentioned during the oral briefing so
she's actually telling the truth here
and the Seth Meyers is just refusing to
believe her and this is what happened in
our politics is that if there's a bad
story about trauma everybody who doesn't
like Trump immediately leads to believe
it if there's a good story about Trump
everybody who likes Trump immediately
leads to believe it is it truth has no
bearing anymore it's just pure partisan
hackery on all sides well we have to say
hello to one of our new advertisers and
thank you one of our new advertisers
blue apron so if you like fresh food if
you are sick of packaged food if you
know some of us don't
time to to actually go out to a
restaurant or some of us actually like
taste of fresh food better food that's
just prepared before you know that you
can prepare yourself but you don't want
to spend all the time going out there
picking all the ingredients making all
the recipes that's what blue apron is
for my wife actually said to me several
years ago wouldn't it be great if there
was some sort of service where you could
order what's in the meal and they just
send you the ingredients and you cook it
yourself so it's fresh and it tastes
better fresh high-quality stuff that's
what blue apron is so for less than ten
dollars per meal blue apron deliver
seasonal recipes along with
pre-portioned ingredients to make these
sorts of delicious home-cooked meals it
is guaranteed they deliver they
guarantee that all of the all of the
ingredients will be delivered ready to
cook and they will be delicious and it
is it is easy they all come with
step-by-step recipes and everything can
be prepared in 40 minutes or less which
if you've ever cooked for a solid meal
that is not a lot of time at all you can
also customize the kinds of meals that
you want based on your preference you
can check out this week's menu and get
your first 3 meals free with free
shipping if you go to blue apron calm /
Shapiro blue apron calm / Shapiro I've
had a lot of family and friends who've
eaten product the blue apron they say
that it is just fantastic first-rate
better than going to a restaurant and
certainly better than getting some sort
of package meal you toss in the
microwave and you don't have to spend
time at the market trying to pick out
the ingredients because blue apron does
all of it for you and they give you the
best recipes it's a better way to cook
blue apron calm / Shapiro to get those
first three meals free and it is a
fantastic service blue apron calm /
Shapiro use flash Shapiro they know that
we sent you and they have all sorts of
by the way different meals that are that
are apparently really really good I mean
it's like chipotle pepper enchiladas
with with sour cream and such I mean
it's really high quality stuff okay so
we're going to say one more thing and
then we will have to break hair so Trump
himself respond and and the way that he
responds is less he has a clear win here
they just say Trump has a clear win
right the BuzzFeed report comes out it's
a bunch of crap and Trump has a very
clear win and the clear win should be
him coming out and saying all of this is
crazy are you guys crazy like what what
in the world what in the world and then
Crump does what from does which is he
make some boo-boos and this is going to
be one of the more epic episodes of good
form
bad from that we've ever done here on
the bench Shapiro show it's pretty it's
pretty epic so why we play the song real
fast there was some certainly epic good
Trump here and there was some relatively
epic bad from so Trump immediately comes
out tweeting about the BuzzFeed story
and here is what she tweets Russia just
said the unverified report paid for my
political opponents is quote a complete
and total fabrication utter nonsense all
caps very unfair ! okay so tip to the
wise if you are trying to tell people
that you do not have associations with
Russian or do you trust them nor are you
in their pocket it's probably not a wise
move to quote them denying the report
okay there are lots of reasons to deny
therefore you should know whether the
report is true since you are the subject
of the report quoting the Russian
intelligence community that just said
that they don't spy on people that's not
your best tack but it continues along
these lines Russia has never tried to
use leverage over me I have nothing to
do with Russia all caps no deals no
loans no nothing which may or may not be
true he's not releasing his tax returns
as we'll get to in a minute so we don't
really know that but we left assume it's
true for a second and then he tweets in
this one is correct I went an election
easily well not easily a great movement
is verified and crooked opponents try to
belittle our victory with fake news a
sorry state fair and then finally he
finishes intelligence agencies should
never have allowed the stake muse to
quote unquote leak into the public I
don't know if you try to make a pee pun
or if he just doesn't know how scare
marks scare quotes work is one last shot
of me are we living in Nazi Germany no
president Trump we are not living in
Nazi Germany president Trump who is the
president of the United States because
you are elected in a presidential
election as the president also typical
tactics of the Nazis did not include
leaking damaging but false information
to the press typical tactics of the
Nazis included murdering your political
opponents imprisoning millions of people
and then systematically killing them
also invading foreign countries for no
reason other than you needed some more
room for Germans so no it's not nazi
germany and again there's there's just
it's in typical good Trump antrim we
have to break here and if you want to
watch the rest
all much more to come you need to stop
by you need to go to daily wire calm
right now and become a subscriber
because the visuals on this are amazing
they're going to want and welcome you're
going to want to see the tape its daily
wire calm eight dollars a month gets you
a subscription if you get an annual
subscription I believe that we're in the
waning days of the you get a free copy
of my novel true allegiance and signed
by me if you become an annual subscriber
with a bunch of new things that are
about to come out for subscribers so you
want to go and get an annual
subscription right now at daily wire.com
we are the largest conservative podcast
in the united states
[Music]